[Music]
I like this one
Bree what was it like joining this group
in this universe I love that this is
good
[Laughter]
intimidating at first mostly because I
this is where it all began for me was on
this film we filmed this before Captain
Marvel but it was a good group of people
to figure it out with right guys
yeah signed you up such an
apprenticeship done what was it like
when semi-new comes in is there like a
Nisshin is the bearer like officer you
accepting you're like I don't know there
was definitely a hazing period she's
still in it
yeah but and it's good because we
actually you get to kind of play with
that we do anyway for sure in the scene
itself when she kind of shows up so it
was nice but she kind of fit right in
she paid her dues on time the initiation
dues are paid promptly so waiting for my
membership card $25 that'll come the
card company will go and then you're in
we lost all of us
[Music]
lost friends you lost family
you lost a part of ourselves
this is the fight of our lives in many
ways this is a ending for others for
some and it's a beginning for others
like Bree how emotionals that same
goodbye to this his family his group
what what I really like saying was on
the day that we who me did that big
photograph and everybody got together
and everybody had a book never I was
going around like it was you know last
day of high school okay could you sign
my book could you sign my book and
there's a real I think affection among
the cast members except for no this is
gonna work Steve I know it is cuz I
don't know what I'm gonna do if it
doesn't expectations are they're saying
this movie could hit two billion easy do
you that love that do you ever think
that through just when we thought there
is nothing else that would come out of
it and if there's new characters and
there's new ways to tell to tell the
stories and new ways that these
characters can interact and develop so
it can just it can go on and on and you
know like I said there's been a sort of
the passing of the torch and Bree just
has to not screw it up any pressure with
that Bree not being the new I felt okay
until he's become
[Applause]
[Music]